Los Angeles donc là tu arrives en boîte
tu vois Mickey la Mickey qui te Chine et
là deux minutes après tu as l'autre gars
qui arrive voilà merci voilà
il a une meuf il y a des meufs il y a
des meufs je vais partir avec le gars là
à mon avis
c'est tous les lait cartonné aux
États-Unis ça sort et normalement c'est
peut-être là on les voit en fait on a
fini les conneries tout est vrai et tout
c'est vrai comment on peut vérifier on
va vérifier on va appeler Mickey de toi
Mickey
qui était à mon avis aujourd'hui il est
là il est toujours de la planète il est
enseignant maintenant c'est toujours un
ami on a écrit des livres ensemble
j'avais fait venir non exactement non
c'est un autre c'est Xavier lui c'est
Jacques
chopé des stars parce que Mikao qui se
tapait les stars toi tu as déjà chopé
les stars ou pas franchement c'était
plutôt des mannequins russes
nous payons tu payes en